hey how's it goin Kraus it's the
multi-millionaire that keeps complaining
about stuff why don't you shut the [ __ ]
up why is he talking like filthy Frank
he's been doing it for two years but now
people are Sonny
point it out so he should just stop he
should just stop talking like that
okay anyway I've recorded this video
four times now that's not how they say
it
I've been trying to record this video
four times now I love when youtubers do
that it's been so hard for me to shoot
this video and to take four attempts Oh
No Oh
anyway it's it's actually taking me four
times to make this video not because
it's hard for me to talk about this but
because things keep changing this whole
fiber thing is so out I just [ __ ] so
much has happened so much has happened
that you don't know even know about I've
literally made three videos I'm just
gonna scrap them and simply gotta
explain what has happened I did my first
video doing fiber requests you pay
people five bucks and they will do take
your requests will paint your message on
my body and dance in the jungle I will
play hearthstone with you three times
well what the [ __ ]
I will finish any math lab web assigned
tasks you can literally cheat at school
math lab some of them did not take my
request but I asked a girl a
mathematician to make a graph out of a
penis remember that if you use abusive
language then we'll be forward to
support team where we can learn how to
[Music]
write proper grammar she didn't want to
do that so she cancelled the order I
asked someone to photoshop a weird
picture or something like that they
didn't want to do that so that so they
cancelled the order but for some reason
these these fiber guys accepted the
order to to write deaf to all Jews on a
message and dance
subscribe to gamestop
the response in the video initially was
really great I knew people would be
offended and I knew people wouldn't like
it but I also knew people would would
see the joke in it and would find it
funny and honestly the comments when the
video came out were like this is the
funniest video I've ever seen
and I'm not just straw picking like it
was generally people loved the video
they thought it was really funny
then people that I think that don't
watch my channel heard about it and they
wanted to get triggered by it and so
they come over to my channel and they're
like you can't do this how dare you put
a pie how dare you tell people these
innocent little boys are like how their
voice whenever it's convenient
those little Indian boys they don't
speak any English they didn't know what
death two meant even though they can
articulate proper full of sentences and
right with proper English grammar they
didn't know what they were doing so
basically what happened was that the
fiber guys the ones who did the video
they got banned from fiber which really
sucks I think it's a it was really
[ __ ] I was really down to hear that
I felt really bad about it so I wanted
to do something about the situation but
at the same time I didn't know what to
do like what do I do
so I try to contact fiber now I managed
to get in contact with someone over at
Fiverr and they're saying that they want
to unbanned them and figure it out so
hopefully it gets solved and we can kind
of just move on the person that
contacted me said they loved at my video
and they thought it was really funny and
the understand but some higher-ups at
fiber Jewish didn't didn't like the
humor I guess and you know what in
fibers defense I can understand that
they don't want their website to be used
to spread you know anti-semitic messages
you know I fully understand that but it
was also not serious I mean it was
clearly a joke and not just fiber guys
got bad I got bad as well so I decided
to make a second video and this time be
a little bit more subtle with my my
hey my hate speech I'm just kidding so I
thought it would be funny just to test
you know test out the waters so
basically there was a girl that would
said she will dance to your music I will
dance to the song you want
that seems wash six dollars please dance
to this tune so I sent her DJ Adolf and
see if she would she would go through
with it cuz I don't know that's just
funny to me
[Music]
when Philip
I asked these cartoon artists who make
cartoon versions of your face to make
one of my granddad
I gotta order one of these amazing
cartoon portraits because I love them
here's a picture of my granddad Joseph
Joseph Cobb bells and then I asked a
Photoshop artist to who retouch his
images to retouch one of my other
granddad could you please make him look
younger fresher etc and it all worked
I had the files so then finally I asked
the costs peach from Metal Gear Solid 5
is just a funniest thing because it's so
dramatic and if you don't know the
context behind it it's just so funny to
me why are we still here
just suffering so I thought it would be
funny someone who's a voice actor or a
really bad voice actor to reach out read
read the cost Beach it amazes me how
these people who claim to be
professional voice actor have at the
absolute worst quality of audio that I
have ever heard but no they wrote this
is sensitive this is sensitive media and
I'm not gonna do it every night
[Music]
what my account got flagged they found
out oh it's Potapov he's up to no good
again and I got bad for the second time
my Fiverr account got banned again I
guess these site just isn't meant for me
is it I don't know when this video is
coming out I'm kind of struggling with
this whole video and at that point I'm
just like what the [ __ ] do I do
god dammit this is so [ __ ] annoying
so of course I make a third account and
I named it jacksepticeye twelve thinking
oh I'll get away with this and this time
I thought okay well now I'm just gonna
play completely PC I'm not gonna you
know do anything that might be
considered offensive and I kept trying
to make orders on Fiverr despite having
a new account it just didn't work
alright so I've been puzzled for the
last 10 minutes why none of my
transactions are going through and then
I found that they are automatically
refunding all my payments they banned my
PayPal account
clearly Fiverr want nothing to do with
me cuz not not only did they ban me
twice they banned my fight my PayPal
account trying to prevent me from make
any other transaction through their
website but of course I got credit cards
alright I'm portable I'm kidding so I
just use a credit card and that worked
so I made a third video completely peasy
okay let's play nice hello pleased to be
working with you I am the famous
youtuber Jack Spade I see and then they
[ __ ] ban me again
goddammit I got bad three times fiber
easy and the ending keeps changing you
know I'm supposed to react to the
bourbon in that get man and then I do it
again and then I get banned i've been
banned three [ __ ] times i got banned
again by Fiverr so meanwhile i'm talking
to this guy trying to unban the fiber
guys they made a video explaining about
their situation then extremely thought
for the mistake we have made in the
video how can you not accept that
apology
look how sad they look beautiful us we
really don't know what the message means
while making the video okay I don't
believe that but regardless they're sad
you know let's get real they know what
deaf to means regardless you watch it
and you can't help but feeling bad for
them they clearly love fiber they
clearly want to keep making videos and I
don't want to ruin that and when they
apologize so I thought for sure that
they would unbend the fiber guys because
it's such a heartfelt apology to me it
didn't make any sense for them to stay
banned and then so I thought ok well
I'll make a video that will help them
get back their account
I'll make some sort of statement I don't
know what I'll do but I'll do it and
then all of a sudden things keep [ __ ]
changing I know it's [ __ ] annoying
but Jesus got Pam hi this is Jesus and I
just wanted to say subscribe to my
favorite channel on YouTube Jax but I
see too so Jesus was another in person
that was in my video and he didn't say
anything offensive at all
look at this hello it's me and I have a
very important update as you know I was
recently featured in a PewDiePie video
and that was great I got lots of traffic
to my Fiverr account because of it yeah
it brought traffic to fivers account it
brought business to this guy he didn't
even do anything bad so Jesus gets
banned now and I'm like well if Jesus
gets banned and they're not on banning
fiber and they banned me three times
they're clearly gone you know they're
not gonna come back to the website fiber
clearly says [ __ ] these guys Jesus says
that he didn't say anything bad but in
my second video I caught Jesus saying
Hitler did nothing wrong
alright I have that on video let's show
that
Jesus here just want to let y'all know
that Hitler did absolutely nothing wrong
what the fire he only wanted to act upon
God's will
don't worry though he stands beside God
now he isn't had wait that's all folks
Jesus out Fiber guys got banned but gee
and I wasn't the one who made him say it
or was it I don't think so
regardless he set up a GoFundMe page and
his own website so you can take orders
from Jesus himself and also let can I
just point out that it's a little bit
ironic that that Jewish somehow found
another way to [ __ ] Jesus over no okay
anyway so I thought okay well this is a
great solution for Jesus Christ had set
up his private web site and you can just
order from his own website Jesus and
fire guys were the most popular people
on the website after I made my video and
they literally got hundreds of orders so
I thought okay well great now they can
just keep to making videos on their own
terms
they don't have to give a split to
Fiverr they can put messages whatever
they want they don't risk getting banned
for no reason whatsoever and they're
living just getting taken away so I was
gonna okay well I don't donate to their
GoFundMe page so I don't hit I was gonna
do it a thousand split into two fiber
guys and and in Jesus so I started with
Jesus I I'll be donating five hundred
okay that's a hundred orders worth I
implore the fiber guys to do the same I
will make the same donation so a
thousand bucks just to get him up there
off their feet
I feel bad this whole thing has happened
and then I was gonna kinda tell the
fiber guys to do the same thing Jesus is
doing and potential to help them set up
their website and I did that and then
they just got on van now they're
unbanned which is great I mean it's
great but I want my [ __ ] $500 back
thank you Jesus what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
annoying this whole situation but
regardless I'm really glad they got
their account
I'm really glad Fiverr decided to not
ban them I had this whole other video
plan where I'm just good literally just
gonna [ __ ] all over you but I think it's
pretty cool that you unban Jesus and the
fiber guys and haven't we all learned
something from this
now despite getting banned from Fiverr
three times and my PayPal account
potentially my credit card there was one
man one man that delivered my request
one man that doesn't play by the rules
of fibre one man who's greater than I
would say anyone that just messages
online I'm talking of course about big
man Tyrone
hi subscribers viewers internet friends
and chicas grubs big matt.taryn here
welcome to the happiest channel on
planet earth where we set goals
advertise products creates fun videos
and generally happy laughs I just wanted
to tell you about my favorite channel on
YouTube Jack septic I - yes that septic
even pronounce it right and that love is
content online PewDiePie who freaking
sucks hey I didn't tell you to say that
but the [ __ ] around also why Hitler
did nothing wrong
okay well I think we all learned a
lesson here and that is if you need a
message online [ __ ] Fiverr you just got
a big man Tyrone the real messenger of
the Internet they're real Jesus Christ
that's pretty much all I've learned and
who knows maybe I'll make another fiber
video in the future also YouTube YouTube
on monetize the video so I didn't make
any any profit of it so you know if you
could if you can maybe refresh this
video a couple times I think that would
be pretty nice I need more money I need
more money because I just lost $500 on
jesus [ __ ] christ